Der Rasenfunk.
Kurzpass. Tja, eigentlich ist der letzte Kurzpass zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer nur drei Spieltage her. Aber was ist da nicht alles passiert? So viel, dass ich heute drei Gäste hier habe im Kurzpass. Und die möchte ich ganz herzlich begrüßen. Es geht der Reihe nach durch. Zum einen Lukas vom Aus dem Exil, dem Fortuna-Podcast, auch als Ad aus Exil auf Twitter zu finden. Dementsprechend einer unserer Schwerpunkte, Fortuna Düsseldorf. Hallo Lukas. Ja, danke, dass du hier bist. Und eine für erfahrene Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörern vertraute Stimme, Tanja Schmidt. Ihr kennt sie vom HSV-Talk, den es wieder gibt. Ihr kennt sie von Friff und sie war auch schon mal, ich glaube auch schon relativ früh im Rasenfunk. Hallo Tanja. Moin. Schön, dass du hier bist. F Schmidt mit DT77 auf Twitter. Und dann haben wir uns aus aktuellem Anlass noch Daniel Cottäus eingeladen von der DeichStube. Als Ed Daniel Cottäus ist er auch auf Twitter. Und er hat gleich die große Ehre, uns dieses ganze Ding rund um Markus Anfang zu erklären. Hallo Daniel. Schön, dass du hier bist. Dann lasst uns gleich damit beginnen. Werder Bremen hat seinen Trainer nicht mehr und es hat ihn unter einem kuriosen Umstand verloren. Markus Anfang hat einen gefälschten Impfnachweis erbracht, war nicht geimpft und dementsprechend wurde er entlassen. Das alles hat sich innerhalb von einer Woche sehr schnell entwickelt bzw. innerhalb von wenigen Tagen. Und Daniel, wenn ich es richtig verfolgt habe, wart ihr mit der Deichstube da immer sehr weit vorne dran. Kannst du uns denn mal so die letzten Tage aus deiner Sicht schildern, was da so alles passiert ist? Ja klar, kann ich sehr gerne. Die waren ja auch für uns als gesamtes Team, ja wie soll ich das sagen, enorm ereignisreich. Das war eine ganz schöne Welle, die da übers Weserstadion und damit auch über uns als Deichstube geschwappt ist. Wenn wir das vielleicht chronologisch ordnen, dann ging das Ganze am vergangenen Donnerstag los, zu einer Uhrzeit, als wir uns eigentlich ja im Grunde alle im Feierabend wählten. Das war kurz vor halb elf abends. Einige Kollegen haben auch schon geschlafen, die haben dann am nächsten Morgen erst erfahren, was da eigentlich abging. Ja, denn um diese späte Uhrzeit hat Werder Bremen noch eine offizielle Mitteilung rausgegeben. Und da war in dem Moment, als die eintrudelte, eigentlich schon klar, okay, da muss irgendwas passiert sein, weil der Zeitpunkt ja schon sehr, sehr ungewöhnlich war. Und so bewahrheitete sich das dann auch, weil eben in dieser Mitteilung der Verein bekannt gegeben hat, dass das Bremer Gesundheitsamt Strafanzeige gegen den Cheftrainer Markus Anfang gestellt hat, weil der Verdacht im Raum steht, dass der einen gefälschten Impfpass vorgelegt hat dieser Gesundheitsbehörde. Und damit ging die ganze –ich hätte jetzt fast gesagt, der ganze Spaß, dafür ist das Thema dann aber doch zu ernst –aber ja, damit ging die ganze Nummer los, auch für uns. Und ihr habt dann auch über diese Pressemitteilung von Werder Bremen erstmalig davon erfahren? Wir haben uns in dem Fall, genau, auch an dem Donnerstagabend davon überraschen lassen. Das war in dem Fall für uns dann neu, als diese Mitteilung kam. Werder muss das vorher gesteckt bekommen haben. Ich meine, das waren die Kollegen von Radio Bremen, die dann einen Tipp bekommen haben und Werder dann damit konfrontiert haben, ja, mit der Bitte um eine Einordnung, eine Stellungnahme. Und zeitgleich am Abend ist dann die Mitteilung rausgegangen und auch der entsprechende Text von Radio Bremen. Genau, sodass sich das Ganze dann im Grunde auf Werder als Quelle dann bezog von dem Zeitpunkt an. Das war der späte Donnerstagabend. Da wusste man von dieser mutmaßlichen Strafanzeige bzw. durch die Pressemitteilung von Werder Bremen, konnte man sich dann schon davon ausgehen, dass es sich jetzt nicht hier um einen kompletten Hoax handeln würde. Und dann ging es ja am Freitag sehr schnell weiter. Und zwar drehte sich da auch meinem Gefühl nach sehr schnell die Position des Vereins. Nimm uns da mal ein bisschen mit. Ja, es war am Freitag so, dass wir natürlich sofort dann raus sind zum Abschlusstraining vom Heimspiel gegen Schalke. Das sollte morgens um 11 Uhr stattfinden. Und im Grunde waren wir uns mit allen Kollegen am Trainingsplatz einig. Markus Anfang wird die Mannschaft kaum auf dem Platz führen. Bei dem, was da im Raum steht, den wird der Verein aus der Schusslinie nehmen, bis das aufgeklärt ist. Ja, und zu unserer allergroßen Verwunderung, Überraschung, kam er dann tatsächlich auf den Trainingsplatz, flankiert von Werders Medien, Sprecher und seinem Co-Trainer Thomas Zichern. Hat die Einheit normal geleitet, hat freundlich gegrüßt, ist danach dann wieder weg, hat sich freundlich verabschiedet. Also so, wie er das in seiner Zeit in Bremen ständig gemacht hat. Und danach ist dann Frank Baumann vor die Kameras getreten und hat im Grunde noch mal den Tenor der Pressemitteilung vom Vorabend bekräftigt und hat gesagt, naja, wir müssen abwarten, was diese Ermittlungen ergeben. Und in einem ganz interessanten Satz gesagt, dass Werder ja keinen Grund sieht, an der Version des Trainers zu zweifeln. Denn ja, jetzt im Nachgang betrachtet, ein relativ pikantes Detail ist, dass Markus Anfang eben in dieser Mitteilung vom Donnerstagabend sich mit den Worten zitieren lässt, ich bin wie jeder normale doppelt geimpfte Bürger auch in einem offiziellen Impfzentrum gewesen, die zwei Aufkleber in meinen gelben Pass bekommen, mir in der Apotheke den digitalen Impfpass geholt. Also mit anderen Worten, ich verstehe die Aufregung nicht, das ist alles sauber. Und das hat Werder natürlich in eine Situation gebracht, sie wussten, da laufen Ermittlungen einerseits, sie hatten andererseits aber das Wort ihres womöglich wichtigsten Angestellten, der intern auch mehrfach beteuert haben soll. Nein, Leute, ich bin geimpft. Ja, da kannst du dich natürlich auch schlecht öffentlich hinstellen und das schon von abrücken von dieser Person. Dementsprechend war das ja so ein kleiner Eiertanz, den Frank Baumann da notgedrungen aufführen musste. Und immer aber noch dabei die Botschaft gesendet hat, naja, das wird sich schon irgendwie aufklären lassen. Und kam dann ja leider anders. Und so, wie man gehört hat, nachdem die Polizei Werder Bremen eine neue Faktenlage –ich zitiere da, glaube ich, Frank Baumann –zumindest indirekt präsentiert hat, das ging dann auch wiederum sehr schnell. Und dann war klar, okay, also Markus Anfang und auch sein Co-Trainer werden von ihren Aufgaben im Bund beziehungsweise haben, um eine Auflösung des Vertrags gebeten. Das bedeutet am Ende das Gleiche, nämlich sie sind nicht mehr Trainer und Co-Trainer von Werder Bremen. Und jetzt so im Nachgang, auch dann nach diesem Schalke-Spiel, was ja sportlich noch mal seine ganz eigene Geschichte geschrieben hat, mit dem Faul-Elfmeter in der letzten Minute, das lassen wir jetzt mal kurz beiseite, sonst wird es noch 20 Minuten länger. Aber im Nachgang habt ihr dann viele Dinge recherchiert, habt auch ein bisschen nachweisen können, woher dann auch dieser Anfangsverdacht überhaupt kam. Kannst du da noch ein paar Dinge zu sagen? Und mich wird auch ein bisschen interessieren, wie die Recherche dazu abgelaufen ist. Ja, das Ganze ist natürlich, wie gesagt, am Donnerstagabend gestartet, was wir eben hatten, und hat dann innerhalb weniger Tage eine wahnsinnige Dynamik angenommen. Du hast es gerade selber schon kurz angesprochen. Am Freitagabend stand die Polizei im Weserstadion mit einem Durchsuchungsbefehl für die Privatwohnung von Markus Anfang und seinem Co-Trainer Junge. Und da haben sich die Ereignisse überschlagen. Und für uns war ab dem Moment, wo wir davon erfahren hatten, natürlich auch klar, dass irgendwie alle Drähte jetzt lühen müssen. Und wir haben uns da dann wirklich geballt hintergeklemmt und haben dafür, dass wir ansonsten als Sportjournalisten ja eher mit Spielern, Trainern, Funktionären reden, mit sehr vielen Menschen rund um die Staatsanwaltschaft, um die Gesundheitsbehörden, um andere Behörden, rund um den Verein telefoniert, um irgendwie dieses Gesamtbild zusammensetzen zu können. Weil sich natürlich neben der reinen Faktenlage, da stehen jetzt Ermittlungen gegen Markus Anfang im Raum, die ganz große Frage gestellt hat, aber wie kann das denn bitteschön sein, dass dieser Impfpass gefälscht ist? Ja und da ist es dann tatsächlich gelungen, ja relativ zeitnah da einige Details zusammenzutragen und die haben wir dann ansprechend auf der Deichstuben-Homepage veröffentlicht. Unter anderem ging es eben dann darum, was in diesem Impfpass letztlich nicht in Ordnung war und den musste Markus Anfang vielleicht das zur Einordnung, was sich ja auch viele gefragt haben, ja wieso liegt denn sein Impfpass beim Gesundheitsamt, den musste er vorlegen nach der Corona-Infektion von Marco Friedl, der sich ja das Virus eingefangen hat. Und dann war es eigentlich ein ganz normaler Vorgang, dass das Gesundheitsamt Werder bittet, so bitte mal Impfausweise auf den Tisch, damit wir sehen können, wer ist nicht geimpft, denn der muss in Quarantäne. Da hat dann auch Markus Anfang seinen Impfausweis vorgelegt und muss dann auf einen Mitarbeiter in dieser Gesundheitsbehörde getroffen sein, der ja extrem aufmerksam war, weil der hat sich als allererstes die Daten von der Erst- und der Zweitimpfung angesehen und hat festgestellt, okay, der ist im April das erste Mal geimpft und im Juni das zweite Mal und hat sich dann aber an einen Vorfall erinnert und das hat am Ende dieses Kartenhaus für Markus Anfang zum Einsturz gebracht, nämlich an einen Vorfall erinnert aus dem August, an dem sich Markus Anfang in Quarantäne begeben hat. Das war Werders Auswärtsreise zum Auswärtsspiel in Karlsruhe. Die Mannschaft ist mit dem Flieger nach Frankfurt geflogen und ein Profi war zu spät dran beim Abflug. Das heißt, dessen Ergebnis vom Corona-Test lag vorher noch nicht vor, sondern erst als die Maschine in der Luft war und das war dann positiv. Daraufhin mussten am Frankfurter Flughafen alle Insassen der Maschine, die nicht geimpft waren, in Quarantäne, darunter auch Anfang und Junge. Und jetzt spulen wir die Zeit wieder vor in den November. Corona-Infektion Marco Friedl und ein Mitarbeiter im Bremer Gesundheitsamt fragt sich, aber wenn der doch im Juni schon durchgeimpft war, wieso hat er sich denn dann im August zur Quarantäne gemeldet? Das war das erste große Fragezeichen und daraufhin haben die Beamten dann genauer hingeschaut und ganz viele kleinere bis größere Ungereintheiten entdeckt. Datum der Erstimpfung war der 20. April. Da saß Anfang allerdings in Würzburg als Darmstadt-Trainer auf der Bank, was Fernsehbilder belegen. Also da kann er nicht in Köln geimpft worden sein. Und ja, Nachforschungen der Staatsanwaltschaft bei den entsprechenden Behörden dann in Köln haben auch ergeben, nein, der ist hier nicht erfasst in der EDV, also der wurde hier nicht geimpft. Die Chargennummern passen nicht. Eine existiert gar nicht, andere ist einer anderen Impfung zugeordnet. Und ja, so kam da immer mehr zusammen. Ein bisschen zum Fakt, dass ja, in seinem Impfpass schon ein Vordruck COVID-19 steht, der quasi das Eintragen oder das Aufkleben, dieser Aufkleber für die Leute, die impfen, leichter macht. Diese Impfpässe sind aber erst seit Mai auf dem Markt und er will ihn schon im April bekommen haben. Und das alles hat dazu geführt, dass Lars Filbri vor Anstoß des Schalke-Spiels schon sagte, also die Indizienlage ist. Das ist erdrückend. Da natürlich noch keine Details nennen, mit Verweis auf die laufenden Ermittlungen. Aber da war eigentlich allen klar, okay, wenn er da jetzt nicht irgendeinen Joker noch aus dem Hut zieht, den wir gerade alle nicht sehen, dann kommt er aus der Nummer nicht mehr raus. Das wäre jetzt auch mal eine Frage gewesen, weil ich ja vermute, dass bei solchen Recherchen man sehr häufig keine zweite Quelle hat, die das noch mal unabhängig bestätigen kann. Da wird man wahrscheinlich sich so von Indiz zu Indiz hangen. Gibt es denn deiner Meinung nach noch irgendwelche Zweifel daran, dass es ein Betrug war, so wie es jetzt für alle aussieht, aber eben noch nicht irgendwie juristisch bewertet wurde von jemandem? Ja, genau, das ist eben der Punkt. Man muss da vorsichtig sein, gilt natürlich nach wie vor die Unschuldsvermutung und man muss das im Grunde alles im Konjunktiv formulieren, aber nach all dem, was inzwischen bekannt ist, was auf den Tisch liegt, was wir auch zusammentragen konnten, habe ich da keinerlei Hoffnung mehr, dass da am Ende noch die große Auflösung kommt, denn wir sind im Laufe des Freitags noch davon ausgegangen, ok, da ist vielleicht ein technischer Fehler passiert, das wird sich aufklären lassen. Ich habe mich da mal schlau gemacht und geguckt, was ist denn eigentlich, wenn ich meinen Impfausweis verloren habe oder auch mein Handy ist kaputt, also ich habe plötzlich kein Dokument mehr, mit dem ich nachweisen kann, dass ich geimpft bin, dann ist das laut den offiziellen Angaben der Behörden relativ problemlos zu lösen, dieses Problem, indem ich mir einfach an der Stelle, wo ich geimpft wurde, einen neuen Nachweis ausstellen lasse. Also wenn denn sein Impfpass nur fehlerhaft gewesen wäre, dann hätte sich das demnach innerhalb von wenigen Stunden aufklären lassen müssen und da da bis heute gar nichts passiert ist, da er sein Amt als Chef-Trainer ja dann auch relativ schnell, nämlich am Freitagabend schon zur Verfügung gestellt hat, ist die Sache ziemlich klar. Dieser Rücktritt, das haben wir uns dann auch sagen lassen, ist juristisch natürlich nicht als Schuldeingeständnis zu werten, aber sagen wir mal so für große Entlastung sorgt es jetzt auch nicht unbedingt. Und gleichzeitig hat er ja auch noch auf seine Antrittspkau oder zumindest einer seiner ersten Pressekonferenzen genau auf diese Frage nach der Impfung geantwortet und gesagt, er sei noch nicht geimpft und würde das jetzt nachholen. Also das ist für mich dann auch sehr deutlich, weil da passen dann auch irgendwann gewisse Abstände zwischen Erst- und Zweitimpfung, die es einfach gibt, die passen dann auch nicht mehr zusammen. Das finde ich insofern aber interessant, weil das ja im Grunde dann die deutlichste Aussage von ihm nach außen hin war. Und das ist ja der größere Zusammenhang. Wir haben jetzt hier einen Trainer, der hat da nach allem anscheinend nach einen Betrug begangen, der aber vermutlich gar nicht so untypisch ist in Deutschland oder nicht so alleinstehend. Dahinter steht ein größeres Problem, nämlich ja auch quasi die Anerkennung von Corona, der richtige Umgang von Corona und dafür ist er jetzt ein Beispiel. Was glaubst du denn, was man in dieser Hinsicht aus dem Verhalten von Markus Anfang lernen kann? Gibt es für dich Grund zum Anlass zu glauben, dass es durchaus stellvertretend für auch andere Leute im Fußballbetrieb stehen könnte? Ich hoffe das natürlich nicht, ich denke mir aber, wenn man sich so die Gesamtgemengelage anguckt, wenn man sich anguckt, wie groß die Fußballbranche ist, wenn man sich anguckt, wie sehr das Thema Corona und vor allem das Thema Impfen ja, Impfen nein in anderen Vereinen auch auf Spielerebene ein Thema ist, glaube ich, ist die These nicht allzu gewagt zu sagen, denn Markus Anfang könnte eben mehr als nur ein Einzelfall gewesen sein bzw. anders formuliert es könnte da sehr gut noch mehrere Fälle geben. Ich weiß das nicht, mir liegt da irgendwie nichts vor, dass das irgendwie erhärten könnte, aber ich kann mir schon sehr gut vorstellen, dass dieses vergangene Wochenende in der gesamten Fußballbranche dem ein oder anderen ja, ziemliche Bauchschmerzen bereitet hat. Lukas, Tanja, ich würde euch beide auch gerne mal an der Stelle in die Diskussion mit rein holen. Tanja, jetzt mal auch jenseits von HSV versus Werder Bremen, vermute ich, dass du das einigermaßen fassungslos beobachtet haben wirst, was da passiert ist am Wochenende.
Mit Sicherheit. Also man hat, wie gesagt, im Sommer fast bis zum Ende noch irgendwie versucht, um Luca Kreins mitzubieten. Letztendlich konnte Hannover dann wohl viel, viel mehr zahlen. Man hat es dann nicht geschafft, noch irgendwie einen Plan B aus der Tasche zu ziehen. Und auch sonst ist es natürlich so, dass man da jetzt finanziell nicht auf Rosen gebettet ist. Aber man hat ja, glaube ich, schon im Vergleich zu den anderen Mannschaften in der Liga, sollte man da ja schon irgendwo so am Übergang vom ersten zum zweiten Drittel irgendwie liegen. Also ich glaube schon, dass da einiges möglich ist. Man hat allerdings auch wirklich in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren sehr, sehr viele, ja, falsche Entscheidungen getroffen. Man hat sehr, sehr viele Spieler verpflichtet, die nicht funktioniert haben. Also nun mal so als Beispiel, die beiden sind die teuersten Positionen, die man bisher so im Kader jetzt im Sommer 2021 sehen kann. Das sind einmal die Raten, die man bezahlt hat für David Kowinjacki, der jetzt seit fast drei Jahren da ist und gar keinen Bein auf die Erde bekommt. Und die Rate für Nana Ampoma, der gerade verliehen ist, aber man muss einfach gerade noch Raten nachstottern. Das sind die beiden teuersten Einkäufe der Vereinsgeschichte der Fortuna. Und ja, das erzählt, glaube ich, schon sehr, sehr viel davon, wie es halt gerade finanziell aussieht.
Also ich habe mal kurz nachgeguckt, die Finanzkennzahlen für die Saison 2019, 2020 sind ja die, die uns vorliegen von der DFL aufbereitet. Da liegt die Fortuna beim Rohergebnis bei 80 Millionen Euro und damit auf Rang 21 von insgesamt 38 Profi-Vereinen. Beim Personalaufwand ebenfalls Rang 21. Also, so wie du es sagst, man liegt da eigentlich genau in dem Bereich, in dem man dann um den Ausstieg mitspielen sollte, ist ja auch das erklärte Ziel. Dass das Beides jetzt nicht immer ganz synchron läuft, ist vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlimm, weil das den Fußball ja auch spannend macht. Aber wo siehst denn oder welchen Eindruck hast du von der Perspektive, die Fortuna Düsseldorf hat? Nach dem, was ich bisher immer so mitbekommen habe über soziale Medien und Fortuna-Fans, die ich kenne, und jetzt auch aus dem, was du gesagt hast, höre ich sehr viel Ernüchterung raus und eher Sorge darüber, dass man sich dauerhaft nach unten, also jetzt für diese Saison orientieren muss. Ist das so die richtige Diagnose von mir?
Ja, irgendwo schon, weil ich glaube, wenn, auch wenn wir uns das alle noch so gar nicht so richtig eingestehen wollen, das ist uns jetzt auch am Montag im Podcast aufgefallen, dass es sich irgendwie noch nicht so richtig so anfühlt, als ob es jetzt wirklich eine schlechte Saison bisher ist. Aber ich glaube, wenn man mit einer Mannschaft nicht Abstiegskampf spielen will, dann ist es diese Mannschaft. Extrem viele Spieler, die die Uwe Klein jetzt verpflichtet hat, sind Spieler, die entweder aus den fünf großen Ligen kommen oder die halt vorher bei Mannschaften wie Olympiakos Pireos oder bei Feyenoord Rotterdam gespielt haben. Man hat da sehr viele Spieler ausgeliehen. Das sind, genau wie auch der schon angesprochene Nedelku, sehr oft Spieler, die halt in den letzten zwei Jahren, deren Karriere in den letzten zwei Jahren stagniert hat und die, glaube ich, alle so ein bisschen die Fortuna als so einen Zwischenschritt sehen, bei dem sie ihre Karriere möglichst schnell wieder auf den Pfad bringen, vor dem sie halt vor ein paar Jahren noch gewesen ist und die sich vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu sehr mit sich selber beschäftigen, einfach weil sie ursprünglich eine andere Idee von ihrer Karriere hatten und ich glaube, die wenigsten waren darauf eingestellt, dass es jetzt eher um so Dinge wie Abstiegskampf geht. Und ich glaube auch Christian Preusser wäre vielleicht nicht der richtige Trainer dafür. Ich weiß natürlich überhaupt nicht, wie er in der Kabine ist und wie er zur Mannschaft spricht. Ich finde ihn sehr angenehm in der Kommunikation, sehr klar, aber was ihm vielleicht ein bisschen fehlt, ist das Charisma. Der hat eben auch bisher nur einmal auf dem Niveau Dritte Liga mal trainiert, auch in einer ziemlich fiesen Situation bei Rot-Weiß-Erfurt. Auch da hat er es letztendlich nicht geschafft, den Karren aus dem Dreck zu ziehen. Ich glaube, so richtig kann man sich sowas auch nicht aus den Kleidern schütteln, wenn es wirklich mal hart auf hart kommt.
Dann habe ich noch eine Frage an dich. Gibt es einen Grund dafür, dass die Fortuna so heimschwach ist? Erst ein Sieg, drei Unentschieden, das heißt, sechs Punkte erst aus den sechs Heimspielen geholt?
Das ist jetzt kein Grund, der mir da jetzt so richtig einfallen würde. Die beiden letzten Heimspiele waren auf jeden Fall schon viel, viel besser als die Spiele davor.
1 zu 1 gegen 1 HSV, diesmal aber den von Hannover 26.
Genau, dann das 3-1 gegen Karlsruhe. Sonst hat es dann irgendwie ein Heimspiel gegen Regensburg gegeben, wo man, glaube ich, einfach in einer sehr instabilen Phase war. Da hat man einfach nur geschaut, dass man irgendwie zu dem Zeitpunkt sehr, sehr starken Regensburger nicht abgeschossen wird. In den anderen Heimspielen waren das irgendwie alle Spiele, wo man versucht hat, mit relativ offensiv starken Gegnern mitzuspielen, offensiv zu spielen. Die haben einfach dann die Lücken, dies in den Abständen bei der Fortuna gab, schonungslos offen gelegt. Man hätte, glaube ich, in all diesen Spielen auch noch viel mehr Gegentore schlucken können. Aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass es ein spezielles Heimproblem ist gerade, sondern das ist einfach ein allgemeines Problem.
Genau, und das hängt ja auch viel mit dem Spielplan zusammen, wenn man nach 14 Spieltagen erst auf solche Tabellen blickt. Deswegen habe ich die Frage auch so offen gestellt. Also, wir werden verfolgen, wie das bei der Fortuna weitergeht. Wie es weitergeht, fragt sich natürlich auch der KSC. Aktuell ist man nämlich das perfekte Mittelmaß der 2. Liga. 21 Tore geschossen, 21 Tore kassiert. Ich vermute jetzt mal einfach 1 zu 1 gegen den HSV gespielt. Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht aus dem Kopf. 18 Punkte hat der KSC. Ja, stimmt. Und wie war der KSC beim HSV, beim 1 zu 1? Hätten sie eigentlich auch gewinnen müssen?
Äh, nee, in dem Falle war tatsächlich der KSC die bessere Mannschaft. Wir haben ein bisschen Glück gehabt, dass wir da mit dem Punkt nach Hause sind. Also sie haben gegen uns, ich glaube, ihre beste Saisonleistung quasi gebracht. Das war offensiv sehr stark. Es hat uns vorher in der Defensive noch keiner so richtig gefordert. Und unsere Abwehr hatte richtig gut was zu tun gegen den KSC. Ich bin auch immer noch ein bisschen überrascht, dass sie sich so mehr im unteren Mittelfeld wiederfinden, weil ich den KSC immer für eine gute, stabile Mannschaft gehalten habe. Und ich auch eine ganze Menge von Christian Eichner, dem Trainer, halte, der sehr geerdet, sehr vernünftig, sehr klar immer in seinen Ansprachen scheint. Und auch so der Kader scheint mir relativ ausgeglichen mit ein paar herausragenden Spielern, wie Philipp Hofmann, der ja auch schon diverse Interessen vom HSV geweckt hat. Aber ich weiß nicht, inwiefern da dann eventuell ein bisschen zu viel Unruhe durch Herrn Hofmann in die Mannschaft gekommen ist. Aber er trifft ja weiterhin fleißig für den KSC. Also ich finde die Mannschaft noch ein bisschen schwierig einzuschätzen, muss ich gestehen.
Also ich glaube, dass der KSC vor allen Dingen am Anfang extrem davon propheziert hat, dass man so eingespielt ist. Also es gab, glaube ich, wenig Wechsel im Sommer. Man hat eigentlich alle Leistungsträger halten können. Und ist jetzt ja eigentlich erst zuletzt so ein bisschen in so einen Abwärtstrend halt irgendwie reingerutscht. Aber ich glaube eigentlich auch, weil der KSC halt irgendwie nichts Aufregendes macht, aber das halt irgendwie sehr, sehr gut. Also man setzt… Ja, ich meine, das ist glaube ich so, dass das auch schon relativ viele Mannschaften in der zweiten Liga so machen. Dass man halt, ja, wie vorne halt so diesen Brecher drin hat. Und gerade die Karlsruhe setzen dann ja irgendwie auch sehr, sehr stark auf Standards. Man hat da wirklich riesige Innenverteidiger, Türme, die halt, die da sehr, sehr gefährlich sind. Dazu passt auch ein Zitat von Eichner, das ich sehr, sehr interessant finde. Der hat so ungefähr gesagt, Ballbesitz, Zweikämpfe, das alles brauchst du in dieser Liga nicht. Die Spiele werden im 16er entschieden. Also das zeigt auf jeden Fall ziemlich deutlich, glaube ich, wie der KSC und wie, ja, an die Spiele rangeht und wie Christian Eichner über Zweigliga-Fußball denkt.
Sehr schönes Zitat. Vielen Dank fürs Raussuchen. Das ist tatsächlich sehr eindrucksvoll. Man hat bisher fünf Tore nach Standards erzielt, 16 aus dem laufenden Spiel heraus. Absolute Standardkönige übrigens Jan Regensburg mit 12 Treffern aus Standard-Situationen, 14 aus dem laufenden Spiel heraus. Also wenn wir später über den Jan sprechen. Ich glaube, ich hilf das auch schon mal jetzt zur Einordnung. Die Standardstärke ist da eins der entsprechenden Elemente, was da dazu gehört. Und ursprünglich, Tanja gehörte das, meine Meinung nach, auch mal zur DNA des FC Heidenheim. Allerdings in der Saison noch nicht so wirklich erst vier Tore aus Standard-Situationen. Dafür steht man insgesamt aber besser da, aber ebenfalls so ein bisschen schwierig einzuschätzen. Also die Tordifferenz ist mit 15 zu 20 Toren noch negativ. Allerdings muss man sagen, es gibt einen klaren Aufwärtstrend. Aus den letzten drei Spielen zwei gewonnen. Rang 8, damit 21 Punkte. Und damit so die letzte Mannschaft, die nicht drei Punkte auf die Tabellenspitze hat. Also zwischen Platz 1 und Platz 7 sind genau nur drei Punkte. Heidenheim ist aber da jetzt auch nicht so weit dahinter. Zu Recht, deiner Meinung nach, wie schätzt du den FCH ein?
Also grundsätzlich bin ich bei Heidenheim immer sehr vorsichtig, weil die machen im nächsten Spiel irgendwas, was mich immer komplett überrascht.
Positiv oder negativ?
In beide Richtungen.
Also das Gegenteil vom langweiligen KSC.
Am Ende kriechen sie sich dann plötzlich doch wieder in die obere Tabellenregion rein, und keiner weiß, wo sie denn jetzt gerade herkommen. Und wieso sie da jetzt plötzlich wieder oben mit dran sind. Aber irgendwie schafft Frank Schmidt das immer, irgendwas aus diesem Kader rauszuholen, wo man auch gar nicht weiß, wie er das macht und wie er aus diesen Spielern dann so viel rausholt, die woanders dann nadenlos scheitern. Ich sag nur Tim Kleindienst, den sie wiedergeholt haben und der jetzt wieder ihr bester Torschütze ist. Irgendwas packt Frank Schmidt da in den Pausen-Tee. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber die sind sehr schwer einzuberechnen. Und man weiß immer nicht so genau, was einen da jetzt gerade erwartet, welchen FC Heidenheim man erlebt. Und übrigens, wir haben unentschieden gegen sie gespielt, aber 0-0.
Ja, verrückt.
Jetzt hast du mir die Forte weggedauert. Ich gucke jetzt bei jeder Mannschaft nach, ob sie auch 1-1 gegen euch gespielt haben. Und erstaunlich offen ist die Antwort, ja. Aber um auf Heidenheim zurückzukommen, Lukas, kannst du uns helfen, den FCH besser zu verstehen?
Ja, es gibt auf jeden Fall so ein paar Dinge, da weiß man halt irgendwie schon, was man vom FCH in Heidenheim bekommt. Also zum einen laufen die unglaublich viel. Die sind auf Nummer 1 bei den gelaufenen Kilometern. Die sind auf Nummer 1 bei den intensiven Läufen, also bei den Sprints. Und ich finde, man weiß eigentlich auch immer, dass wenn man gegen die spielt, alle 10 Felspieler auf dem Platz wissen genau, was sie zu tun haben. Die arbeiten halt irgendwie als Einganzes. Die haben halt immer ein extrem aggressives Pressing, das einen extrem unter Druck setzt. Das werde ich übermorgen auch sehen, weil die da gegen die Fortuna spielen. Das macht mir auch echt wieder so ein bisschen Sorge. Und man weiß eigentlich auch, dass die immer extrem gefährlich über ihr Flügelspiel sind. Die haben dann da auch mit Kühlwetter und eben mit dem angesprochenen Kleinsienst auch zwei extrem gefährliche Leute vorne drin. Ja, und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, das wird am Ende der Saison für irgendeinen einstelligen Tabellenplatz reichen. Die werden sehr, sehr viele Spiele irgendwie zu Hause noch 2 zu 1 gewinnen. Die sind auswärts irgendwie immer gut genug mit dem, was sie gut tun, um halt irgendwie den Plan des Gegners zumindest mal gut zu durchkreuzen, dass es dann so ein 50-50-Spiel wird. Und ja, das reicht dann halt irgendwie dafür, um in der oberen Tabellenhälfte zu landen.
Ja gut, und dann kann es ja sein, dass sie da dann noch weiter oben reinrücken und genau das, was Tanja prophezeit hat, eintreten wird. Da müsste allerdings auch Tanja dein HSV mitspielen. Der liegt auf Tabellenplatz 6. 23 Punkte hat der HSV 5-mal gewonnen, er hat 8-mal unentschieden gespielt. Wir alle wissen, wie diese Partien ausgegangen sind. Einmal erst verloren, das ist, denke ich, herauszustreichen. Das heißt, der HSV ist eine Mannschaft, die schwer zu besiegen ist, die es allerdings auch manchmal nicht schafft, ihre Überlegenheit in Siege umzumünzen. Zumindest war das so mein Fazit einiger Spiele, die ich so mit einem Auge gesehen habe. Mit 23 Punkten, 3 Punkte hinter Tabellenplatz 1. Da ist alles mit drin. Und trotzdem ist beim HSV sehr viel wieder los. Auch emotional. Zumindest ist das jetzt meine Ferndiagnose. Stimmt die denn?
Es ist definitiv viel los, auch auf dem Platz. Also das sogenannte Walther-System, wo du, naja, einige bei uns haben es schon beschrieben als E-Jugendfußball, alle hinter den Ball her.
Ein bisschen ungerecht, oder?
Ja, ist es definitiv. Also es ist auch schon besser geworden. Das ist nicht mehr ganz so Vogelwild wie am Anfang. Man merkt, so ein wenig haben die Spieler das auch raus. Aber sie laufen sehr viel, sie laufen sehr intensiv. Also es sind auch wirklich schöne Spielzüge dazwischen. Deswegen war der Tobi jetzt am Wochenende beim Spiel gegen Regensburg auch so begeistert, weil das war richtig Fußball, was sie da zwischendurch durchgespielt haben und es sah richtig, richtig gut aus. Nur des Öfteren haben sie einfach vergessen, die Tore auch aus den Chancen herauszumachen. Dann endet so ein Spiel halt 1-1. Wenn du dann auch hinten dumme Fehler machst und so ein paar Unkonzentriertheiten drin hast, und dann hast du da plötzlich ein Gegentor und schaffst das vorne nicht die Dinger, deine vielen, vielen Chancen auch irgendwie reinzumachen.
Das war eben auch das, was ich mitgenommen habe aus den Spielen, die ich gesehen habe. Eine zum Teil absurde Dominanz. Es liegt auch daran, dass der HSV, die Mannschaft mit dem mit Abstand meisten Ballbesitz der 2. Liga ist 63 %. Dahinter Werder ist schon 6 % Punkte dahinter. Und man macht aber auch was mit diesem Ballbesitz. Das ist jetzt nicht nur hintenrum, sondern insgesamt spielt man sich dann auch die zweitmeisten Torabschlüsse der Liga heraus. Da liegt Werder auf Platz 1. Allerdings ist der Unterschied da nicht so hoch. Zum Teil ist es absurd, wie die Chancen vergeben werden. Gleichzeitig fand ich es aber auch absurd. Es ist erklärbar, aber es war immer wieder seltsam zu sehen, dass egal welcher Gegner gegen den HSV gespielt hat, jeder Gegner konnte auch gefährliche Konter fahren. Und wenn er die mal erfolgreich abschließen konnte, dann wurde schon mal ein 1 zu 1. Und manchmal wurde daraus auch eine Niederlage, manchmal haben es aber auch die Gegner nicht geschafft, und der HSV konnte das gewinnen. Fehlt die Balance in diesem Walther-System?
In einem gewissen Maß. Also man muss halt sehen, dass gerade in den ersten Spielen stand die ganze Mannschaft wahnsinnig weit hoch. Also das fängt schon mit dem Torwart mit Heuer Fernandez an, der fast am Mittelkreis immer dann bei Ballbesitz steht. Und entsprechend sind dann auch die Innenverteidiger und die Außenverteidiger sehr weit mit nach vorne gerückt. Und dann ist halt ein dummer Fehler, ein kleiner Ballverlust im Mittelfeld ist dann sehr schnell ein Gegentor. Also ein Konter, den du dir kassierst und dann steht es halt dumm da. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen besser geworden. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es wirklich am System liegt oder dass Daniel Heuer-Fernandez seit drei Spielen ausfällt und da für Marco Johansson im Tor steht, der einfach nicht diese Spielstärke von Heuer-Fernandez mitbringt, sondern am Ball eher so der Bruder-Leichtfuß ist und man möchte ihn nicht unbedingt in Bedrängnis bringen mit dem Ball. Und deswegen steht man so ein bisschen tiefer. Und seitdem ist es auch nicht mehr ganz so vorgewühlt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich die Absicht von Tim Walter ist oder ob das jetzt einfach der Not geschuldet ist, dass Daniel Heuer-Fernandez immer noch ausfällt. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was passiert, wenn er wieder da ist.
Tim Walter ist ja ein Trainer mit einer klaren Philosophie. Und das ist jetzt auch nicht überraschend, dass der HSV so spielt. Also das ist weiter Fußball. Und das kann man dann despektierlich eh Jugendfußball nennen. Man kann aber auch sagen, ist ja schön, dass jemand versucht, den Ball zu haben und mit dem Ball etwas zu machen. Und eher nach der Devise, wir wollen ein Tor mehr schießen, als wir kassieren, als nach der Devise, wir wollen 1 zu 0 gewinnen. Glaubst du denn, das passt zum HSV und zu dem Kader, den er zur Verfügung hat? Ähnliche Frage, wie ich sie vorhin mit Christian Preusser gestellt habe.
Ich glaube schon, zumal Tim Walter ja auch sehr viele Möglichkeiten hat, den Kader selber zu formen, sozusagen. Er hat sehr viele junge Spieler mit drin. Wir haben zusammen mit Werder den jüngsten Kader der Liga. Und da kann er sich seine Spieler wirklich in sein System so einbauen und so zurecht erziehen, dass es passt. Und man hat das auch in den vergangenen Spielen gesehen. Da kamen dann wirklich junge Leute da mit rein, wie gegen Regensburg, die Torschützen. Ali Duh ist 20. Suhonen ist 20. Ludovic Reis ist 23. Wir haben dann Sonny Kittel, unser ältester Feldspieler, und der ist 28. Das sagt schon einiges über die Mannschaftsstruktur aus. Und dass Tim Walther sich da auch wirklich seine Leute heranziehen kann. Das scheint immer mehr zu greifen. Es sieht teilweise also richtig nach echtem Fußball aus. Das kennt man so gar nicht im Volksspiel.
Und trotzdem habe ich schon gelesen, dass angeblich, ich weiß es ja nicht, der Trainerschuh von Tim Walther zwischendurch schon gewackelt haben soll. Gibt es denn die Aussicht darauf, dass er mal ein Trainer sein darf, der tatsächlich auch die Zeit bekommt, die es vielleicht braucht, auch vor allem mit diesen jungen Spielern etwas zu formen? Das Thema hatten wir aber in der Fortuna vorhin auch. Junge Spieler, die sehr viel Verantwortung tragen, da kann man nicht davon ausgehen, dass das funktioniert. So funktionieren Menschen, so funktionieren Leistungssportler nicht.
Also der Stuhl von Tim Walther hat wirklich bedenklich gewackelt. Und so nach einem der zahlreichen Unentschieden dachte ich mir auch schon so, oh, das geht nicht über die Winterpause hinaus. Jetzt scheint es aber doch ein bisschen besser zu werden. Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass Jonas Bold einfach die Geduld hat. Weil Bold sagt, unser Saisonziel ist Entwicklung. Wenn wir nebenbei um Aufstieg mitspielen, super. Wenn wir den Aufstieg schaffen, yay. Aber wenn wir es nicht schaffen, so what? Hauptsache, wir entwickeln Spiele und wir entwickeln Werte. Weil dem HSV geht es finanziell immer noch nicht besser. Nach jetzt im vierten Jahr 2. Fußball-Bundesliga. Also wir können nicht mehr fertige Spieler kaufen. Wir sind darauf angewiesen, dass sie eventuell dann das Wettbewerb haben und die Ablöse frei zu haben sind. Wie es bei Jonas Meffert und Sebastian Schonlau jetzt der Fall war. Aber ansonsten müssen wir halt zu sehen, dass wir Leute selber ausbilden. Und dafür ist Tim Walther wirklich gut geeignet. Und das geht zumindest die AG-Führung im Augenblick mit. Wir haben übrigens noch einen Finanzvorstand, aber im Sommer nicht mehr.
Warum auch? Ich hoffe es. Den naheliegen Gag lasse ich jetzt einfach mal liegen. Das sind für mich neue Töne. Sind die mit Jonas Beuth eingekehrt beim HSV? Wie hat sich denn der Verein in seiner Struktur verwandelt? Weil ich glaube, da haben viele Hörerinnen und Hörer schon am Rande was mitbekommen, unter anderem, weil mit Marcel Jansen jemand sehr Prominentes als Präsident fungiert. Und Jonas Beuth ist ja auch ein bekannter Name. Die bekanntesten Namen vom HSV saßen immer auf der Trainerbank, weil die so schnell gewechselt haben, waren die häufig in den Medien. Hat sich da deiner Meinung nach jetzt auch dann tatsächlich was in der Strategie nachhaltig verändert, auch jenseits von Jonas Beuth?
Ich glaube schon. Ich glaube, dass viele im Verein verstanden haben, dass dieser ständige Wechsel auf sämtlichen Positionen –das war ja nicht nur die Trainerposition, es waren ja auch tatsächlich die Vorstände Sportschefs und so weiter. Die haben ja genauso häufig gewechselt wie die Trainer. Und das kann irgendwann nicht mehr gut gehen. Und da brauchen wir diese Konstanz. Jonas Beuth ist jetzt seit zweieinhalb Jahren in Amt. Das hat seit der ersten Ära Dietmar Beyersdorfer keiner beim HSV geschafft auf seiner Position. Das sagt schon eine ganze Menge. Jonas Beuth ist mit den Worten angetreten, wenn ich jemanden zwei Jahre vollmache, ist das schon ein Erfolg. Und ja, war es, dass er die tatsächlich geschafft hat und sein Vertrag dann verlängert wurde. Er hat offensichtlich ein Konzept. Es ist völlig überraschend für mich, wenn der Mann seine Entscheidung erklärt. Ich verstehe sie, also ich kann das nachvollziehen. Das ging mir jahrelang nicht wirklich so, dass ich irgendwelche Transfers komplett nachvollziehen könnte oder irgendwelche Entscheidungen. Also die Entlassung von Daniel Tune hat mir persönlich, rein menschlich, wirklich wehgetan. Aber die Erklärung, die da hinterher kam, die konnte ich nachvollziehen. Das konnte ich alles verstehen. Und das ist neu beim HSV. Wir haben einen Sportvorstand, der Dinge erklären kann und auch in einen Kontext setzen kann. Und das fühlt sich ganz gut an, muss ich sagen.
Ja, das glaube ich. Ehrlich gesagt ist das das, was man dem HSV als neutraler Beobachter und als neutrale Beobachterin gewünscht hat. Auch das, was dann Leute wie ich auch fälschlicherweise gedacht haben, einen Abstieg könne, das bringen, eine Bereinigung in Anführungszeichen. Also ich möchte jetzt nicht Menschen als mit Schmutz gleichsetzen. Also falsche Analogie, aber quasi ein Wechsel in den Strukturen, der eben auch für eine neue strategische Ausrichtung steht. Ist da neben Jonas Beuth noch jemand Wichtiges zu nennen? Wer sind da die entscheidenden Leute?
Da gehört natürlich auch noch, wir haben noch dabei einen Sportdirektor, das ist Michael Mutzel, der auch dann die Kaderplanung mit übernimmt. Dann der Scouting-Leiter, Klaus Koster, ist auch noch durchaus wichtig. Das ist ein Triumvirat, die machen das unter sich aus und diskutieren Dinge und am Ende steht eine Entscheidung. Irgendwo mischt dann noch mal Horst Rübersch mit rum. Der ist jetzt sozusagen festangestelltes Faktotum. Und dann läuft das so. Es scheint tatsächlich Teamarbeit zu sein. Es wird auch immer wieder betont, dass Entscheidungen im Team getroffen werden und keine Einzelentscheidungen oder Alleingänge gemacht werden. Das ist auch durchaus ein Fortschritt, weil das war jahrelang nicht so. Da haben Menschen ihre Vision durchgesetzt, die dann leider komplett in die Hose gegangen ist.
Und wie ist das mit der –jetzt hätte ich es fast Öffentlichkeitsarbeit genannt, aber das meine ich damit eigentlich gar nicht –ist es noch so, dass man sehr viele Dinge in der Zeitung oder in Medien erfährt, noch bevor sie eigentlich offiziell kommuniziert worden sind? Das ging ja in der Vergangenheit –und davon spreche ich jetzt aber schon von vor ein paar Jahren –dahin, dass laufende Aufsichtsratssitzungen fast schon live getickert wurden. Also so ähnlich, wie man das bei Koalitions- und... Nein, bei den Ministerpräsidenten hatten wir das ja, als wenn die sich getroffen haben. Da gab es ja auch live Ticker mit SMS aus der Sitzung heraus. Hat sich da auch etwas verändert beim HSV?
Also ich finde schon, dass es durchaus ruhiger geworden ist. Ich meine, habt ihr mitgekriegt, dass Klaus-Michael Kühne fünf Prozent seiner Anteile abgegeben hat? An einen lokalen Unternehmer, der dann jetzt auch demnächst einen Platz im Aufsichtsrat einnimmt. Aber alles komplett so ganz ruhig geblieben. Auch dass Frank Wettstein im Sommer seinen Vertrag nicht wiederverlängert, unser Finanzvorstand, den wir noch haben, ist eigentlich relativ ruhig aufgenommen worden. Also aus dem Aufsichtsrat wurde das nicht verkündet, sondern es ging dann tatsächlich über die Vereinsmedien, das gesagt wurde hier. Vertrag verlängern wir nicht. Wir suchen da jemanden neuen. Und wenn sich dann der neue Aufsichtsrat, der sich jetzt irgendwann im Winter bilden wird, zusammengesetzt hat und konstituiert hat, dann gucken wir mal, wie wir den Vorstand in der kommenden Saison aufstellen. Ich hoffe, dass Jonas Boldt dann immer noch mit dabei ist. Das wäre mir persönlich sehr recht.
Nach dem, was du bisher erzählt hast, kann man das dem HSV nur wünschen. Jetzt gehört aber natürlich zum HSV dann auch die Tradition mit dazu. Das ist manchmal etwas Schönes. Und manchmal ist es, glaube ich, auch eine Bürde. Du hast ja jetzt sehr nachdrücklich diesen Strategiewechsel beschrieben, dass man eben sagt, Aufstieg würden wir eher mitnehmen. Das Wichtigere ist jetzt, Spieler zu entwickeln. Im Grunde ist das ja eine komplette Neuausrichtung des HSV und auch eine Neupositionierung, bei der dann auch die Anerkennung des Fakts mitschwingt, dass man eben nicht mehr zu den besten 18 Mannschaften in Deutschland gehört, sondern zu den ersten, was weiß ich, besten 20, 25, wie auch immer das genauer definiert ist. Ist diese Botschaft deiner Meinung nach auch im Umfeld angekommen? Und welche Resonanz gibt es da?
Das ist ein sehr, sehr schwieriges Thema. Also davon abgesehen, wir sind definitiv festgelegt Platz 22 im deutschen Fußball, weil wir in der zweiten Liga. Das ist ganz klar. Aber es ist im Umfeld tatsächlich schwierig. Deswegen gibt es auch die Unruhe dann um Tim Walter, weil viele nicht sehen wollen, das braucht Zeit. Wir brauchen da Entwicklung und es ist irgendwie in vielen, vielen Köpfen immer noch drin, dass der HSV auf den ersten drei Plätzen liegen muss. Ansonsten ist das kompletter Murks- und eigentlich Abstiegsgefahr. Es ist wirklich schwierig. Man hat das Gefühl, dass einige Menschen, die in verantwortlicher Position sind, es mittlerweile endlich verstanden haben, dass wir ein Zweitligist sind. Das ist nun mal so. Das muss man dann akzeptieren. Wir haben jetzt auch eine Mannschaft, die durchaus in der 2. Liga angekommen ist. Wir haben keine Spieler mehr darin, wo man sagt, das ist ja eigentlich ein Erstligaspieler. Nein, davon haben wir keine Spieler mehr. Seitdem Aaron Hunt jetzt auch aufgehört hat, oder quasi aufgehört hat, und Bobby Wood in die 3. Amerikanische Liga mittlerweile abgeschoben wurde, ist das einfach auch ein Zweitligakader, den wir haben. Dann muss man mal gucken, wie sich der entwickelt. Man muss die Geduld aufbringen. Wir haben überhaupt keine andere Option mehr. Aber bis das tatsächlich in allen Köpfen angekommen ist, das wird noch dauern. Das wird ja auch von außen ständig reingebracht, dass der HSV eigentlich in die 1. Liga gehört. Nein, tun wir im Augenblick nicht.
Na gut, eigentlich ja schon. Aber aktuell mit diesen sportlichen Rahmenbedingungen und so weiter nicht. Aber das ist halt dasselbe, mit dem der 1. FC Kaiserslautern in die 1. Liga gehören würde. Von dem, was man fußballkulturell mitbringt, von der Geschichte, von der Tradition, gehören solche Mannschaften in die 1. Liga. Sie verdienen es aber sportlich nicht, deswegen spielen sie dann auch nicht.
Ja, aber entsprechend gehören sie da ja auch eigentlich nicht hin.
Ja, genau. Ich verstehe schon deinen Punkt. Ich will nur die Argumentationslinie, die da herangetragen wird, nachvollziehbar machen. Gibt es denn da einen Unterschied zwischen den Hamburger Medien und der überregionalen Presse? Der HSV ist ja immer noch eine Mannschaft, die ja nicht nur in Hamburg Fans hat und die auch für Fans anderer Vereine interessant ist. Deswegen wird, glaube ich, auch über den HSV immer noch anders berichtet als über andere Zweitligisten.
Das glaube ich auch. Also, so einige Geschichten, die lassen sich dann auch gar nicht regional klären. Also, irgendwie die ganze Geschichte im Baccariata. Das hat, glaube ich, komplett Fußball-Deutschland mitgekriegt. Aber wir versuchen es irgendwie schon, uns ein bisschen kleiner zu halten. Aber selbst bei den Hamburger Medien sind wir halt, trotz der aktuellen Tabelle, immer noch die Nummer 1 in der Stadt.
Aber seid ihr auch quasi die Nummer 1, die eigentlich aufsteigen müsste? Auch bei den Hamburger Medien? Wie ist da so die Darstellung?
Ich glaube, fast bei jeder Pressekonferenz wird noch mal gefragt, ob man denn aufsteigen möchte. Und irgendwann ist es ja auch ein bisschen nervig. Und deswegen kam halt auch von Jonas Beuth der Satz, wir wollen aufsteigen, aber wir müssen es nicht. Das ist genau die Aussage. Und ja, das ist eigentlich auch das Einzige, was du in Hamburg irgendwie verkaufen kannst. Dass du immer natürlich das Ziel hast, 1. Liga, aber ob sich das realisieren lässt, das steht auf einem ganz anderen Blatt. Das muss man gucken, wie die Saison läuft. Da gehört viel Glück zwischendurch dazu. Und dass man irgendwie nicht zu viele Ausfälle hat, dass sich einzelne Spieler tatsächlich so entwickeln, wie man sich das vorstellt, dann kann das hinhauen.
Aber ansonsten …Ja, und vor allem gehört auch eine Resilienz dazu. Vielleicht schlage ich jetzt den Bogen ein bisschen zu weit. Da darfst du mich gerne einfangen, wenn ich falsch liege. Aber das sind alles Dinge, die du jetzt erzählst, wo ich mir denke, boah, ich möchte wirklich nicht beim HSV verantwortlich dafür sein. Und erklärt es dann nicht auch, warum der HSV so oft jetzt schon letztlich an dem Druck gegen Ende hin der Saison zerbrochen ist und eben einfach auf diesen verdammten 4. Platz gelandet ist. Das scheint ja fast gar nicht anders möglich zu sein, wenn es eben so anders läuft als bei vielen anderen Vereinen in der 2. Liga, wo es eine Jagd nach dem 3. Platz gibt. Und beim HSV gibt es immer schon ab Spieltag 25 den Witz, wann fallen sie denn jetzt raus? Wie versammeln sie es denn diesmal?
Ja, also ich glaube auch, dass tatsächlich das Thema Druck durchaus groß ist. Ich glaube auch, dass es eben das Thema war, woran Daniel Thun in der vergangenen Saison eigentlich gescheitert ist, weil plötzlich war eben genau das, was du schreibst, einfach da. Die Ergebnisse stimmten dann nicht mehr so ganz, und dann war hier und da wirklich ein unglückliches Spiel, und da hieß es dann außer kompletten Stadt einfach nur, oh, jetzt geht das schon wieder los. Jetzt versagen wir uns jetzt wieder. Und aus diesem Hamsterrad kam Daniel Thun dann auch nicht mehr raus. Und selbst Horst Rubesch hat es in den letzten drei Spielen nicht komplett zum Anhalten gebracht. Also das ist wirklich schwierig. Und ich glaube, dass sich die Verantwortlichen beim HSV dieses Themas auch durchaus bewusst sind und dass sie auch Versuche haben. In der vergangenen Saison hießen sie Säulenspieler, wie Simon Therodde, Toni Leisner, Sven Ullrecht, die dann da installiert wurden, um junge Spieler so ein bisschen zu schützen, damit die sich im Windschatten akklimatisieren können. Und jetzt hat man immer noch Säulenspieler, aber die sind nochmal wieder ein ganzes Stück jünger. Also Tim Leibold ist 27, Sebastian Schonlau ist genauso alt, Sonny Kittel macht jetzt erst den Schritt zum Führungsspieler und der ist aber mit seinen 28 dann halt auch noch nicht jetzt wirklich so ein alter Haudigen. Aber das muss man halt gucken, ob man mit diesen Spielern dann jetzt tatsächlich es schafft, den Druck ein bisschen in die Breite zu bringen, sodass es nicht mehr so auf einzelnen Schultern irgendwie lastet und dann die Mannschaft erdrückt.
Ja, Druck, manchmal wird er auch zum Rückenwind, aber das ist wirklich unglaublich, wie sich der HSV in allen Belangen gewandelt hat. Und selbst wenn jetzt ein Aufstieg klappen würde, womit man ja gleich zu Helden der Stadt werden würde, auch völlig zu Recht, dann wäre ja die 1. Saison auch wieder unglaublich schwierig zu bestreiten, aus sämtlichen Aspekten her. Und eben halt auch schwieriger als bei anderen Vereinen, die aufsteigen, der HSV. Das ist schon wirklich, ja, ist eine ganz besondere Nummer. Danke, dass du uns da mal ein bisschen Einblick gewährt hast. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie sich das weiter entwickelt. Wir haben aber noch zwei andere Vereine, über die wir sprechen wollen, nämlich unter anderem dem SSV Jan Regensburg. Tanja darf uns da gleich sagen, was sie beim 4 zu 1 gegen Regensburg so beobachtet. Lukas, dich würde ich aber auch gerne an der Stelle wieder mit in die Runde reinbekommen. Regensburg, lange Zeit an der Tabellenspitze oder in der Spitzengruppe mit dabei gewesen. Das ist man jetzt auch immer noch. Man ist auf Rang 4 mit einem Punkt Rückstand. Also jetzt sind wir bei den Mannschaften, die wirklich eng beieinander liegen. Darmstadt 26, St. Pauli 26, Paderborn und Regensburg 25, Nürnberg 24, HSV 23, Schalke 23, Heidenheim 21. Richtig, richtig schön eng und richtig interessant. Was macht Regensburg aus und sind diese zwei Niederlagen, die man sich da jetzt zuletzt geholt hat, das 1 zu 4 beim HSV und das 2 zu 3 zu Hause gegen Hansel Rostock? Deiner Meinung nach ausrutscher oder gibt es da größere Probleme?
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das Wort ausrutscher das richtige Wort ist. Ich kann mir aber schon vorstellen, dass hier an Regensburg sich jetzt wieder so ein kleines bisschen Richtung Mittelfeld der Liga langsam orientieren wird, ohne dass die jetzt aber irgendwie abstürzen werden. Ich glaube, wenn man da mal ein bisschen über den Kader schaut, dann würde ich schon denken, dass man jetzt im ersten Saisondrittel doch auf jeden Fall überperformt hat. Ich glaube, Regensburg hat extrem davon profitiert am Anfang, dass man sehr viel Kontinuität im Kader gehabt hat, dass man eigentlich kaum Spieler verloren hat, dass man mit derselben Mannschaft wieder in diese Saison gegangen ist. Dass man bisher auch so viele Tore schießt, ich glaube nicht, dass das langfristig haltbar ist. Man hat, glaube ich, immer noch den zweitbesten Angriff nach Darmstadt. Damit hat wahrscheinlich niemand von uns vor der Saison gerechnet. Ich glaube aber trotzdem, dass man halt schon aber auch noch seine Punkte sammeln wird, um halt eine komplett ruhige Saison halt zu spielen. Man hat da schon einfach noch Stützen, auf die man bauen kann. Man hat extrem gute Standards, weil man da eben auch gute Schützen hat mit Jan-Niklas Beste und Zarpet Singh, und man hat mit Max Bisuchkov einen Strategen, der mir extrem gut gefällt im zentralen Mittelfeld. Ich glaube, das wird jetzt halt irgendwie einfach eine ganz angenehme Saison ohne jegliche Art von Abstieg sorgen. Und dann kann man sich im Hintergrund ganz entspannt neu aufstellen für die Zukunft. Und das muss man ja auch da ja der Geschäftsführer Christian Keller, der Regensburg ja so ein bisschen, ja man kann vielleicht sogar sagen, gerettet hat aus der Viertklassigkeit, ja bis jetzt an diesen Punkt geführt hat. Und währenddessen irgendwie auch noch mehr oder weniger finanziell saniert hat. Der hat jetzt ja aufgehört vor ein paar Wochen und wird dann nächstes Jahr, wie ich gestern gesehen habe, beim 1.
Ja, das ist eine sehr interessante Personalie, die du da angesprochen hast. Da möchte ich für alle Köln-Fans, die an diesem Punkt nach Informationen lechzen, auf den Kurzpass, wo wir den Schwerpunkt auf Regensburg gesetzt haben, hinweisen. Da haben wir auch über diese Personalie gesprochen. Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen das größere Bild. Tanja, du hast wie gesagt ja Regensburg jetzt auch gerade im direkten Duell mit dem HSV erleben dürfen. Was ist dir davon hängen geblieben, außer vier Toren vom HSV?
Ich war ein bisschen enttäuscht. Ich hatte ein bisschen mehr erwartet von Regensburg, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Aber die hatten dann natürlich auch ein bisschen Verletzungspech. Alexander Meyer, ihr erster Torwart, war nicht dabei. Steve Breitkreuz war nicht mit dabei und so weiter. Das können sie dann nicht so ohne Weitres kompensieren. Ich glaube auch, dass Regensburg am Anfang überperformt hat. Und dass es sich aber auch wirklich bezahlt gemacht hat, dass sie in der vergangenen Saison, wo es dann oft oder auch lange gegen den Abstieg ging, dass sie da an Merzad Icenembegovic festgehalten haben als Trainer. Und dass sich diese Konstanz jetzt in dieser Saison einfach auszahlt. Das ist in der 2. Liga unglaublich wichtig, dass du Konstanz in deine Mannschaft reinkriegst, dass du eine eingespielte Truppe hast. Du kannst nicht jedes Jahr irgendwie einen Neuaufbau machen. Das hat der HSV mehrfach bewiesen. Drei Jahre hintereinander geht nicht. Und du brauchst diese Konstanz. Und genau das macht Regensburg richtig gut.
Das hat mir auch damals thematisiert, vor allem am Saisonanfang. Das hat ihnen sicherlich geholfen. Das haben wir damals auch ausführlich behandelt. Deswegen können wir an der Stelle weitermachen. Und auf die letzte Mannschaft gucken, über die wir noch sprechen wollen. Nämlich der SC Paderborn, ebenfalls mit 25 Punkten. Dritter in der Liga aus den letzten drei Spielen. Sieben Punkte geholt, zwei Siege, ein Unentschieden. Lukas Paderborn, macht wieder in vieler Hinsicht Spaß, nach dem, was ich so mitbekommen habe.
Ja, das sieht für mich auf jeden Fall auch so aus. Ich glaube, ganz viel von dem, was man da tut, ist mit dem Namen Lukas Quasniung verbunden, mit dem Trainer. Nachdem man Baumgart im Sommer verloren hat, hat man jemanden gefunden, der für eine ganz ähnliche Art von Fußball steht. Der hat auch ein klares Offensivkonzept verfolgt und der, glaube ich, aus der sehr viele Automatismen und Abläufe von Baumgart mehr oder weniger übernehmen konnte. Was die Paderborner bisher sehr gut machen, ist, dass sie auswärts punkten. In sieben Spielen haben die fünf Siege geholt und zwei unentschieden. Ich habe die Paderborner ja auch in Düsseldorf einmal gesehen. Da haben die dann drei zu zwei gewonnen. Das hätte aber auch viel, viel höher ausgehen können. Was da vor allen Dingen Sven Michel, der sogar schon zwölf Mal getroffen hat, in dem Spiel mit der Düsseldorfer Innenverteidigung angestellt hat, da haben die vermutlich heute noch schlechte Träume davon. Die Offensive läuft auf jeden Fall. Ich finde es auch extrem bewundernswert, dass in der Innenverteidigung mit Uwe Huenemeier die Verlässlichkeit in Personen auch ein Innenverteidiger spielt, den ich im ersten Jahrzehnt dieses Jahrtausends verorten würde. Er ist jetzt aber einer der besten Innenverteidiger der Liga in dieser Saison. Und man hat das Gefühl, egal wer da in Paderborn arbeitet –das ist jetzt im Hintergrund gerade der Sportdirektor Fabian Wohlgemuth, der auf Markus Krosche gefolgt ist –irgendwie finden die immer ihre Spieler. Das sind immer irgendwelche unbekannten Spieler, von denen man vorher noch nicht gehört hat. Man kriegt die aber immer eingebaut, und das funktioniert letztendlich.
Tja, so würde man sich das doch für seinen eigenen Verein auch wünschen. Tanja, warum höre ich immer von Simon Terodde, aber so selten von Sven Michel? Zwölf Tore in 14 Spielen ist ja eine Sensationsquote.
Das weiß ich auch nicht. Ich meine, ich möchte Simon Teroddes Lebensleistung wirklich nicht runterspielen, was der Mann in der 2. Liga runter weg trifft und so weiter. Das ist wirklich bemerkenswert. Aber was Sven Michel in dieser Saison bringt, das ist auch aller Ehren wert. Das muss man dazu sagen. Mal gucken, ob er das durchhält. Ich meine, man muss ja auch dazu sagen, dass er mit Felix Platter auch noch jemanden neben sich hat, der auch ganz gut dabei ist, was das Toreschießen betrifft. Also zumindest schon mal sechsmal auch noch dazu getroffen hat. Das ist schon aller Ehren wert, was Patterborn da bringt. Weil man hat im Sommer auch wirklich nicht damit rechnen können, eben der Wechsel von Baumgart zu Quasniog. Das war so eine bisschen Wundertüte, was macht Patterborn da jetzt raus? Aber das sieht wirklich gut aus, was die machen.
Außer sie spielen zu Hause gegen den HSV 1 zu 2 verloren. Wie konnte denn das passieren?
90 plus 4 haben wir das 2 zu 1 gemacht. Also eigentlich war es ein 1 zu 1.
Okay, Mensch, jetzt wollte ich... Jetzt habe ich ein Gag zu Lastnis HSV gemacht. Du hättest die Poente komplett rausnehmen können und sagen können, das war ein super verdienter Sieg. Wo ist jetzt eigentlich der Witz? Und setzt dann selber die Poente drauf. So ist es in der zweiten Liga. Ihr zwei, wir hätten noch viel zu besprechen, was zeigt, wie interessant die zweite Liga ist. Ihr habt aber sowieso schon krasse Überstunden gemacht dafür, dass das hier eigentlich ein sogenannter Kurzpass sein sollte. Aber Markus Anfang und alles, was da passiert ist, hat es nötig gemacht. Und ich bin auch sehr froh und danke an dieser Stelle nochmal ganz herzlich Daniel Cottäus, dass er sich die Zeit genommen hat, uns das nochmal so auseinanderzudröseln, dass da auch wirklich keine Fehldarstellung mit drin sind in dieser ja dann doch etwas heiklen Auseinanderangelegenheit. Entschuldigung, so wollte ich sagen. Also Daniel Cottäus in Abwesenheit, ganz herzlichen Dank für deinen Besuch, Daniel Cottäus, auf Twitter. Und euch beiden möchte ich natürlich nicht weniger danken. Tanja Schmidt von Früff und vom HSV-Tag, die F Schmidt mit DT77 auf Twitter. Tanja, schön, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk warst. Das hat richtig Spaß gemacht. Das freut mich sehr. Ich drücke dem HSV sehr die Daumen. Ich weiß, dass mir das manche HSV-Fans nicht glauben, aber es ist so. Nach dem, was du heute gesagt hast, ist das Daumendrücken noch ein bisschen fester geworden. Das wäre doch richtig schön, jetzt mit einer guten Strategie, mit einer neuen Strategie, dann auch sportlichen Erfolg zu haben. Ja, das stimmt, langweilig wird er tatsächlich nicht. Das ist für ein Format wie den Rasenfunk gut. Langweilig wird aber auch die Fortuna selten. Das muss man wirklich sagen. Der Fußball unter Friedhelm Funkel, den möchte ich da ausklammern. Denn das war manchmal ein bisschen zäh. Aber was da so passiert ist und was sich ja auch sonst noch so getan hat, das haben wir jetzt gar nicht angesprochen. Die Fortuna gehört zu den Vereinen, die versucht haben, bei der TV-Geldverteilung wirklich eine Reform in Gang zu setzen, zu der es ja dann letztlich nicht gekommen ist. Also die Fortuna ja auch noch einer der wenigen eingetragenen Vereine, die es im Profi-Fußball gibt. Auch immer interessant. Deswegen ganz herzlichen Dank an Lukas von Aus dem Exil, dem Fortuna-Podcast, Ed aus Exil auf Twitter. Danke dir, Lukas, dass du dir die Zeit für den Rasenfunk genommen hast.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Danke dir, Max.
Ja, dann auch euch herzlichen Dank, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern der Rasenfunk. Er ist werbesponsor und payboy-frei. Wir sind allein Hörerinnen und Hörer finanziert. Und unsere Gäste haben auch Anteil an dem, was ihr uns überweist. Sie bekommen ein kleines Honorar. Wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Und danke an alle, die das jetzt vielleicht noch tun werden. Ihr unterstützt damit nicht nur den Rasenfunk, sondern alle, die darin beteiligt sind. In diesem Sinne, bis bald, hier wieder im Rasenfunk.